this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu
I cushion in there which means that I'm
relying upon you to do two things I rely
upon you to read caballo dr. Joseph
Bettencourt's you can be as incredibly
impressed as I have did with his work
and then you can also google his name so
we're going to encourage you to take
responsibility for your own learning and
to do those two things so let's save
time well you know I am calm centered
and balanced right now after this
morning I want to thank you all first of
all thank you for that kind introduction
I want to thank you all for taking time
out of your busy schedules to come and
share this discussion and this is a
discussion because this is a movement I
don't come here to speak to you and tell
you about what the right things are I
come to you humbly as somebody who is
with you in the battle to achieve global
health equity and domestic health equity
and just share with you my thoughts and
my perspectives along my road and
hopefully have a chance to learn from
you as well so I thank you all again for
your attention and your kindness and I
look forward to answering questions as
we go through just to tell you a little
about what I do and more importantly why
I do it and then we're going to jump
into our discussion today I am currently
a practicing internist it's been around
30 percent of my time practicing
internal medicine in Boston I am the
director of the disparities solution
Center and the reason I want to bring
that up is because I think our Center
which is about three years old is a
little bit different than a lot of the
research centers that we see around the
country kageura very very very important
I think helped shape the research agenda
and answer very important questions for
us what our Center hopes to do with Mass
General is to take all this wonderful
knowledge and work in partnership with
those research centers and really
translate all that research into policy
and practice to work with health plans
health centers local and state
government health plans to get them to
do something about disparities whether
it be to develop a strategic plan
whether it be to identify and collect
race ethnicity data
just to do something and that's been my
mission and that's the mission of my
Center I also teach in the area of
cross-cultural education both at Harvard
Medical School international hospital
again trying to get my colleagues to
care more about this issue and to do a
better job with every patient they see
regardless of their race ethnicity
culture class or language proficiency
more important let me tell you why I do
this work I am originally from Puerto
Rico I grew up about 30 blocks north of
here and a little bit west on 155th
Street in Riverside Drive where the
issues that we talk about here every day
were things that I saw in my family and
things that I got to experience once I
had the good blessings of going into
medical school and things that I got to
see is one of a few spanish-speaking
Latino medical students to see how
important the issue of language was and
really to learn every day that we were
understanding and being taught all these
wonderful algorithms for caring for
people with high blood pressure for
managing diabetes and asthma but if we
couldn't communicate with the patient
care for them and get them to buy into
what we were trying to do it all meant
nothing and every day I saw in my
various places of training how people
were receiving a different quality of
care based on their race ethnicity
culture class and that's what we call
the status today that's had many names
and it's not a new issue and I'm going
to talk about some more recent work but
my work did not discover disparities I'm
just trying to shine different lights on
it to get people to care at the end of
the day now what I hope to do today
briefly is really talk about the
intersection between racial ethnic
disparities and cross-cultural care and
what I want to do is I want to tell a
bit of the story as I do that and I want
to just spend a tiny bit of time on some
data you know what are disparities kind
of how are we pitching this when I go on
speak to which is what I do the most try
to get speak to people who really don't
understand this issue and I'm trying to
get them to care how do i frame it up
for them how do I try to let them
understand it and talk about disparities
in health and healthcare then what I
want to do and I think it's very
critical to do this is to bring the
patient's voice into the room I want to
take a minute a few minutes to to bring
the patient's voice and I'll explain how
we're going to do that but I think it
would be very powerful very moving and
it will give all this data and all this
to work and all this commitment that we
are sharing here today and will give it
energy because we will see how people
are really struggling with this issue
how there are faces behind this this
data that we'll be talking about today
and then end with just a couple points
what can we do what are the daily things
that we can do what are the little
things that we can move this out argue
that everybody can do something in their
day to day work that can help make a
difference on the issue of equity and
eliminating disparities so to jump in I
just want to share one day slide this is
the diabetes related death rate in 2004
and here you see deaths per hundred
thousand population and this is bigger
that came out of the federal government
the part of Health and Human Services
this data merger this movement emerged
to President Clinton initiative on race
in 1999 going into 2000 and here what we
see is when you look at the diabetes
related death rate any stratified by
race ethnicity we see differences and
how that comes when you stratified by
race right so you see white black /
African American Hispanic / you know
American Indian / Alaska Native an Asian
Pacific Islander and these are what we
call disparities in health and I'll
mention two quick things about the slide
number one we probably know the most
about black-white differences in this
country because of the way we've
collected data many of our state's of
collective health statistics using two
or three categories white not like a
white black another so that comes to
learning about the disguise of health
for some of these other communities
we're getting there and I think we're
just at the tip of the iceberg the other
important point that I would make here
is that you understand them within every
one of these bars is incredible
diversity in one bar and not in a whole
populations experience make so here you
see african-americans flash black and
the difference in diabetes compared to
whites but thinking about that bar and
how within that bar represented
immigrants from the African continent
african-americans has been here for
several generations individuals of
African descent from the Caribbean if
you look at the expect life you know to
begin incredible diversity every one of
these groups has incredible diversity if
we are ever ever going and really
to the point where we eliminate and
address and eliminate disparities we
need to dig underneath those big
categorizations because what we're doing
with this data is just more stereotyping
we're just using generalizations it does
give us a 30,000 foot look at the issues
but clearly we understand that for
example of newly immigrated El
Salvadorian immigrant is going to have a
lot more challenges with imagine diet of
their diabetes then perhaps a Puerto
Rican who's been here for two
generations speaks the language well can
read write and knows how to navigate the
system through trials and tribulations
over time and so we have to look at
those subgroup differences and that's
something that we preach all the time to
folks when we talk about this
disparities work but at the end of the
day I think it's important to look at
this one day of slide and say well why
do we see these disparities what is
going on what are the major causes for
these disparities and I think filling
what you understand as you look at those
differences is that some of those same
communities that are doing poorly as it
relates to imagine right their diabetes
and dying at greater rates from it or
also some communities that have lower
socioeconomic status have lower access
and higher level education
live in environments with greater
occupational and environmental hazards
right and those are what we call
especially in the public health world
social determinants these contribute not
just a domestic disparities contribute
to global disparities poverty lack of
education public health issues related
to just sanitation contribute
significantly a global health
disparities but they still sit here in
this nation with us every day
contributing to the disparities we see
as we know minorities are over
representative when those individuals
who suffer from these social
consequences if we think about asthma
I've had the great pleasure of speaking
of groups here in this room around
asthma in the past and you know if we
just put out the block and draw a line
on 96th Street and we look at the
prevalence it's above 90 60 and below
under 60 it's worlds apart and we can
literally track those out of asthma
epidemics to where we see filling
stations incinerators diesel bus routes
poor housing so we'll never eliminate
disparities talking about the right
medications to give patients unless we
really engage in a lot more than health
policy which is social change changing
issues all the way from living wage to
housing to the environment that's when
we can really eliminate stress we're
talking about diabetics and if I'm able
to tell my diabetic patient that they
should walk and they should eat the
healthy you know the right healthy foods
yet they live in a community there's no
sidewalks it's dangerous to walk at
night and all they have is small bodegas
in the neighborhood that just have
processed foods with long shelf life and
they'll healthy fruits or vegetables and
if they haven't they're more expensive
which you all have seen in the
literature those individuals at a
disadvantage
doesn't matter what medication I give
them so social determinants are really
critical in this movement it really is
about change in a much larger way social
determinants be largest contributor
again going back to asthma three out of
the five largest landfills and for
minority news in the United States so we
know the impact of these issues is of
the weights of the pediatric asthma
epidemic we see among minority children
so that's the largest cause and I think
that's a big daunting task so that's
something we need to take on every day
and there's no two ways about that we do
that with policy and politics
the next largest contributor is access
to care and we know that you have a
diabetic an asthmatic who's depending on
an emergency room or an underfunded
Community Health Center to not only
prevent disease but to take care of that
condition they're going to be a
disadvantage we know that there are 46
million dollars short of uninsured
Americans about 1/4 of them are Hispanic
left you know despite
expect like you know as composing 13%
population so here's a group that's at a
big disadvantage but it's important to
note that 9 out of 10 of those Hispanic
individuals were uninsured have somebody
in their family who were in the
workforce that tend to work in
occupations that don't provide
employer-based health insurance such as
a service industry agriculture Latinos
so again access to care will get us one
step closer towards addressing this
package the universal health care will
not make the strategies go away they can
important message is something you need
to consider the area that I do most of
my focus on although I work on social
determinants and work on access is the
issue of health care and that is the the
third contributor that is rarely spoken
about but I think has gotten greater
attention
last few years and this is research -
the merger began asked a couple of very
basic questions if you live in the same
neighborhood and if you have insurance
as your white count important your
personal color and you go to an
emergency room with chest pain are you
in that white individual very likely to
receive the same quality of care for
your chest pain if you compared to a
white college as a person of color
presents in the emergency room with a
long bone fracture fracture of your arm
or threat to be live are you and that
individual likely to get the same amount
of pain medication for that same crash
if you are white individual I have
end-stage renal disease and on
hemodialysis and you're waiting for a
transplant are you in that wedding
dividual equally as likely to be on the
real transplantation list and what the
research has shown in the last 10 to 20
years is without meaning to every one of
those studies that I've just told you
minority is significantly less likely to
get the same amount of pain medication
in the same emergency room for a long
bone fracture less likely to put on a
real transplantation list and not
because they didn't want to and more
likely to receive lower quality care for
their chest pain than their one
confidence that's what we call the spasm
healthcare that's when they take out
access to care and you take out social
factors and I think for the healthcare
community that is something that doesn't
feel good there's a very prevalent not
me phenomena it's it's not me I don't
treat patients differently that that
doesn't happen here maybe it happens in
that hospital over there because we are
raised in an environment to believe that
we treat everybody the same and we were
raised in the environment to believe
that that non-medical factors can't
impact the way we treat people that we
can't stare at but that's not something
that we do we're above that we train to
be above that I think the realities are
very very different
and this research I think led to a very
important bit of work that I had the
great honor and pleasure of being
involved with which was the Institute of
Medicine report that came out in 2002
incredible on equal treatment where
Congress asked us to say are these
disparities real and if they are tell us
why and tell us what we can do about
them and in 2002 after looking at over
600 articles in the peer-reviewed
literature after having profession
and patient testimony after doing focus
groups after really leaving no stone
unturned a group of 14 colleagues and I
came out as out he said the societies
and healthcare are real they occur to
you when you control for access and
social factors they occur in a variety
different clinical conditions even when
you control for all the usual suspects
that my peers will say cause the
strategies yeah that's more about access
than anything else well it's actually
not just about access and what we said
was that this isn't about blinging right
this is about wagging our finger and
saying you know somebody's fault it's
all of our responsibility and at the end
of the day there's many sources that
contribute to the strategies and there's
no one suspect and there's no one
solution and so that was the IOM report
unequal treatment released in 2000 while
you've seen it get a chance to just
download the executive summary because
the one benefit of this report again
this report did not discover the stress
but the one bathroom of this report is
that the Institute of Medicine is a very
mainstream well rest well-respected in
the health care world institution that
when it speaks people listen for better
for worse and so what this did was it
added a certain promise or certain
mainstream to the issue disparities that
perhaps didn't exist although the
National Medical Association and many
other actives have been talking about
this for over 100 years so very very
important report I think it has given us
a set of findings and recommendations
that I'll share with you that still
drive our work today but what I want to
do now is I'm done shaping up the data
what I want to do now is bring in the
voice of the patient to give this some
flavor and to do that I want to share
with you a brief documentary video from
a series called worlds apart I'm just
gonna take a step back just to say how
this product of all and a chance to
listen to Robert Phillips
several years back there was a great
book that was written called the spirit
catches you and you fall down if any of
you heard of that book yeah it's a
wonderful book really documents the
experience of a mom family run
California child with seizure disorder
they describe her seizures the spirit
catch in her phone
now they're trying to do love I heard
they're bringing to a health care
doesn't understand their ways their
perspectives and and I think there's a
real clash of cultures and the outcome
is not so good it's a wonderful book
written by an fad and I recommend
everybody to grab it if you can shortly
thereafter there was a filmmaker by the
name of Martin Monson who we got to know
and she said you know such a wonderful
book she had done documentary film she
was a physician it's a physician done
doctor reformer particularly around end
of life and death and I'm and said you
know I'd love to bring that fat on this
book to life you know this kind of clash
of cultures and real time after
individuals with their experiences with
the health care system that again could
could help move people and help them
discuss these issues in ways that are
meaningful important and we worked with
her and she followed for patients and
their experienced real time at the
health care system and we put these and
she put these into about ten minute
video vignettes just so that you can
hear the patient's voice
I say the one on the bottom is an
eccentric a perfumer actually lives here
in New York with asthma and multiple
chronic conditions and she tells her
story if you haven't seen this this says
really wonderful the woman on the left
with the child of the child name is
Justine it's a nice easy young they
ocean child with a hole in her heart an
atrial septal defect and a family
struggling with whether to get her
surgery and what that starving religious
a very powerful story the gentleman up
top was Mohammed coach an Afghani man
with gastric cancer at the time of the
side how he's gonna handle this division
and then we have Robert Phillips will
tell you this story from his perspective
so let me just switch this on and what I
encourage you to do is listen to Robert
listen to what he talks about as it
relates to his experiences listen to his
perspective and think about some of the
root causes and solutions for the issue
that he raises for us and so off we go
new days are always in a book did you
know that second time for
four-and-a-half hours okay
when you come back you still have
tonight the things that you still
completely so y'all was behind Haitians
have to credit my ambition it's like ice
cream you like punk servicing you want
to kind of like move up quickly people
ask you to do a lot of things that if
you tell them no they won't ask you to
do anymore
so I just had to kind of like reconcile
the fact that there's some things I
won't get a chance to do
I've been on analysis inactive
imagine yourself sitting in that ship
for hours and then parts new body you
can and then you get uncomfortable
towards the end of it for most things
time to happen to do that you can't
really explain but you still can't get
up start to stay there
one of the realities of being a house as
it kills you it wears your body so the
longer your eyes the weaker you get and
you know at some point there's something
goes wrong you may not make it
I wish adopters were more concerned
about how we cope like staff here is
great and that's kind of like what
balances it out for meaning that the
nurses in the text here have been very
very helpful the doctor is on the other
hand and maybe it's just not that wrong
about position to be that person but it
just had to assume it would be because
they at least in terms of preparation
and ability to cope they have the most
specialized dream
he's very aggressive society because he
feels like over the years this doctor
hasn't given him the best care possible
right and you can see the response from
a doctor with him it's like what not
they know what if you know I'm sure the
help this person who's coming at me like
that right why did is he so hostile and
he's I don't know what I'm telling them
so if you pick me up and he's not doing
when I say so you've got two times right
in the african-american he is a big part
of our experience I mean it's a number
of things but it kind of is a more
recent and poignant experience that
large segments of the african-american
communities for many with and its color
it's only for a generation of that
direction is coming the behavior when it
comes to medicine and and that
generation just impulsively doesn't
trust doctors
even checking up on it we're trying to
rush the process just don't wash your
car they get alert when you call to us
and then I told you the glint type is
dis and this is why you on the list
and when you rise to the top I'll call
you don't call me on one that's not your
sponsee they'll aim at got a lot of
patient playing calling me I'm kind of
mad at this you make my job harder
leave it alone I get in touch with you
for you go right that's what I'm saying
there's more light up your office it's
like damn why do you keep calling me I
told you last week you got three years
call me when you got two years
everyone everyone
and you know I suggested me that I call
them every week just a button
but you know what I need to keep Andy
help me out
I'm gonna call them just a bunch
you come because if I don't have it I'll
have problems so you know respond me
according they don't respond to me like
you know wow that you have to pull out
every time I call you
there is the attitude like no sanity
carousel appointed working it out but
there's someone else was more productive
member of society by fitness and then
there's also this perception that an
african-american man there's
hypertension and diabetes just gonna
ruin it anyway so why give him a kidney
when all these are the folks were more
deserving she did it which is nonsense
nonsense
most of my patients here either prepare
transplants or going to have transplants
was the african-american men here the
kind of headed for the Lama I know
there's research back that up a lot of
quantitative research about them but and
I don't really just seemed like there's
a big disparity of a painter spinner and
a lot of folks voices particularly in
their despair you can hear I mean when
they talked into Protestant lights on
their projects in the bronze is bad news
No
this is implicit belief that genetically
generally match up an african-american
with a white or Asian
even someone who was Hispanic
anecdotally enough alive interracial
donor relationships so that can work and
it's not few and far between there a
number of them wise system can't support
that as well intense one 1095 over 42
being Santa and some days it's a chore
got a will yourself to do
okay so that is the human face of this
package and that's what we do why we do
what we do and I think Robert really
very powerfully talks about the root
causes that we found you don't study
this for it's fastly you studied this
for two years and came up with all these
findings and Robert Robert says you know
what we found after two years he says in
a matter of ten minutes and he talks
about some of the cube root causes of
his experience the complexity of the
system the variety of other things I
think are really really important and
these were key lessons for me and usual
key lessons for me as I went through the
IOM but then I came then again for
Robert what does Robert say as he talks
about this issue of disparities in
health care What did he say he says well
you know and inside of these as well you
know really see how I'm disappointed in
the doctor but maybe that's not their
role in the healthcare system to listen
to care maybe that's not their role and
so we've come pretty far away from I
think when we aspire to be as clinicians
if we have patients saying you know
doctors not they're listening maybe
maybe you know maybe that's not their
role in the health care system and
here's this is played out a large survey
by the Commonwealth Fund you talk about
communication and understanding your
doctor where they have several thousand
patients in the last few years if you
had one or more of the following
communication problems when
communicating with your doctor and here
you see broken up by very sentencing
these problem include understanding the
doctor feeling like the doctor listened
and if you have questions that you
didn't feel comfortable asked right and
so you do see about twenty percent of
all patients about one in five that one
of the more these communication problems
when they saw health care provided over
the last years but then let's break it
down by race about 16 percent weighs
about one in four African Americans and
about one in three Hispanic Latinos and
three asian-americans so when you talk
about communication problems there and
we understand clearly a lot of research
has shown us the importance of
communication the patients who feel like
they communicate effectively with us
tend to follow our recommendations that
greater rates tend to be more
cooperative and tend to have better
health outcomes so the communication is
one very very important part of the
process and so here we have a whole
group of people people who are suffering
from the status who are having trouble
communicating thus and Robert gives
voice to another thing that Robert
mentions is this assumptions right he
says you know I think doctors assumed
that if you just give a kidney to an
african-american patient this can go
ahead and ruin it anyway right he talks
about these assumptions and this concept
the stereotypes right and what's
interesting is a lot of the static links
to the literature I when I mentioned
that study where African Americans like
you know significantly less likely to
get pain medications with the same exact
bone fracture as their white
counterparts anniversary's you might
begin to hypothesize that it's because
healthcare providers are assuming that
those patients with pain medication
seeking and they're gonna wait till that
actually comes along before they give
them the payment you might and in the
study one of the studies that was done
on a renal transplantation similar
Roberts case where they saw that
african-americans were significantly
less likely to be put on the transplant
list and their white counterparts that
research should link back and ask the
patients are you not on the list is you
didn't want to be able this then what
the researchers travel is a slight
difference in after Mary's going to be
on the list but it didn't explain a much
larger disparity and then getting put on
the list so you couldn't say is about
patient preferences so you have to
wonder why do we see these disparities
and it's also important to understand
that if I have a patient who has
end-stage renal diseases
who's on hemodialysis and I want to get
them on the transponder I refer them to
a nephrologist right and that if Rhonda
says to fill out a whole form - okay
this patient to put them on the transfer
list and there's a lot of objective
measures on that wrench that list
referral form right that include you
know you have terminal cancer that
preclude you from being honest you have
HIV AIDS or some terrible disease that
would preclude you from me unless
there's certain things that because
organs are scarce resource that they
jump you out the list but in addition
for the objective measures I think which
is which are important and are
evidence-based there are a couple of
subjective measures and one of the
minutes do you think this station can
adhere to a very complex
immunosuppressive regimen really take
care of that kidney and has this patient
had any mental health problems in the
past that might preclude this patient
from being able to carry through this
very rigorous procedure and that's left
all the decision-making and the
subjective decision-making of a
clinician who maybe is meeting his
patient for a first use two minutes and
that has to pass these doesn't sound ish
and so for me I'll take this concept of
assumptions and start typing was
fascinating perhaps one of the most
interesting things that I learned as
part of my Institute of Medicine
experience right because here's the deal
we we began in our discussions in the
IOM to talk about root causes and you
know the clinicians in the group said
you know we don't you know I mean we
don't treat patients different you know
and and we had a couple of social
psychologists who were on our committee
and they said you know it's really nice
that the clinicians aspire to not you
know succumb to any stereotypes because
it's not the way humans work and of
course so what do you mean you know how
does that how does that occur and they
said well you know they began to educate
us right they say you know we as human
beings take information and put it in
folders in our heads there's a great
book by Malcolm Gladwell called blink
that talks about so whole chapter on
this and you can go to this website it's
called the implicit rwu the implicit
association test and you can actually
look at when you have subconscious
preferences and let me talk you through
this a little bit more so in this stage
we take information and we put in
folders in our nets and when faced with
a situation we take that information
that's on the top of the folder that and
these these that process happens in the
blink
literally like that a flash it's so
consciousness you take these assumptions
in the anyhow right and you know in some
ways that gut instinct can be very
helpful to you but in some ways it can
betray you right and let me give you a
clinical example this and how this works
you know in the first and second year of
medical school when you see a patient
with a fever and cough you get to spend
three hours of that patient right asking
them all types of you know lovely
questions how they travel to the desert
at any point you know have they been to
a conference where they might get you
know Legionnaires you know you have
three hours where you can sit and spend
in kind of you know get all this
information and you know write this
glorious fifteen page know that maybe
five people read in the chart
you know it's magnificent and you know
that's all good and you have a
differential diagnosis a list of that
thing that could be causing the people
in the pockets maybe ten things long
right and that's great works what you
learn now then what happens when you're
a third year medical student I only have
an hour of elevation and you can get you
information the same pace with a call or
an intern now you think they're playing
patients and they have a half an hour to
take those what happens well you know
you're beginning to gain experiences
right you see fever and cough are
usually these three things so that's
where you begin and that's what you call
it quick-connect the cognitive here
sticking that helps you because you
can't generate a twenty three
differential diagnosis for everybody
you'd never be able to see all the
people you need to see it's impossible
right so you get condition this is
helpful in this this is an example of
where these quick connects can be
thoughtful you could always rule out
other things but you know that's where
you'd begin if you guys stay and that's
happening incredibly did I develop
clinical sense and also solve it so
about what they were social psychologist
begin to say is you know it can be
helpful in certain circumstances but not
so helpful in others and particularly as
it relates to stereotyping for these
quick and I surround people based on
your experiences things you've seen in
the media things you see on TV and
things you hear about different people
so experience you think that have and
they say that we all stereotype we all
make those quick connects automatically
and we started taking group
characteristics to individuals and then
we don't want it when we don't know
we're doing well we don't think we're
doing it and they say that we all look
for cognitive shortcuts it's the way the
- life so it's not about you being
purposely racist it's about the fact
that this is just a normal doing process
that can go very all right
it could go over the wrong way and they
say that we stereotype the most on
issues we can see with our eyes race
gender and age and here's the kicker
they say we stereotype the most these
stereotypes are activated them all so we
don't even know it even well intentioned
they're activated the most when we're
stressed we're on a time constraints and
when we're multitasking that doesn't
describe the health care so here you
have you know health care providers
beepers going off the nurse is calling
the writing a chart they're making some
waters and they gotta make a decision
about whether this person can be
adherent to an immunosuppressive regimen
or whether this person really has pain
in their you know due to this potential
practice right and so let me just tell
you my personal space does I ain't heard
this and I was still a little doubtful
Isis don't I don't think I do it you
know I'm like the Sperrys guy you know
I'm not treating my people differently
I'm like you know I'm looking out after
mom making sure that I'm not succumbing
to these positions right and so you know
I had to go home that day Social
Psychology talked about this and I went
home to the hotel room that night after
we had a debate tonight you know how
myself glass of wine trying to kind of
shake and shake things loose a little
bit just kind of relaxing you know
getting a calm centered and balanced and
I still have to say you know you want
stare at that if I ever done that why
did that and I began my clinical
practice here you know less than 10
years ago when I was affiliated with for
now a lot of my patients because I was
speaking about 75% of my patients
came from this neighborhood from Queens
you know from the Lower East Side and
you know I can up your son loved them
speaking Spanish all times and it's
great I want to be well by then and it's
flu shots in some time it's October
right and so I'm excited I'm gonna get
all my patients flu shot and you know
I'm looking out and it's all gonna work
out so it's great and my first one thing
I'm patient comes in and she sits down
man 15 minutes to see her by the way she
does asthma and diabetes and high blood
pressure might get her a flu shot and I
began to see a new not a single da cunha
importante live beginning influenza you
know the whole scoop and snap and you
know ten minutes walking through this
whole thing with her and I'm waiting for
that yes and she's smiling and smiling
you know you're no fun okay not having
don't want and I have five minutes on
this to do it you have that experience
you know I start pull hasn't crossed
total tools did you hear anything you
know like in family experience and your
perspective about the flu shot you know
on times up okay well let's check your
hypertension diabetes or next next lucky
coefficients say you know guess what
go back and forth you know nine minutes
I put it down extra minute and I say see
ya
no okay I don't want okay all right so
two down then the next lucky guy if she
comes it on and say you know guess what
today's your lucky day I have like ooh
now I'm gonna give it to you you know
and it's doing you know he killed by the
way you know so now I'm trying to scare
a little bit you know
not the cold you know this is like
serious business I need somebody to get
a flu shot
things are getting hot on my counter so
a flu shot and give myself one like some
fake a flu shot we're going this whole
thing and no flu shot
and so all I know right I'm going
through October I'm going to November
maybe 90% of my life my patients are
finished up and in January called the
wall and patient number 485 sits in
front of me and so the hypertension
diabetes
how many minutes and how do you think I
offered the flu shot there
it was more like 30 seconds Isis your
hypertension IVs ever but I have a flu
shot you probably don't want it but you
just let me know if you do I don't have
to give you and you know right so what
happened to me I had condition right
some normal experience I began they all
like the most part like the flu shot and
I fell into that same trap man what did
it do just change the way I want it
completely I wasn't saying that I'm
offering it the way I've offered the
people in the first couple months and so
I was I had fallen suspect and I began
to think how many times of my training I
heard the terms you know these patients
were getting that surgery she's getting
for me so that's a little complex just
you know keep them on medical magic oil
you know those patients I can Commodore
these patients those fish not just based
on register they sell a lot of different
characteristics so so listen for that
these these patients and it was very
very real to me and people always ask
what instructing our patients I learned
the lesson that year right so you know
starting out with a 10-minute lecture
like this which I was not the way to go
and I used some different cross-cultural
skills and I began by saying how do you
understand the flu shot first question I
ask because I want to offer to you have
any fears concerns and the conversation
was very different way more fish
because I learned you know that their
concerns were not unlike other patient
concerns you know they got the flu shot
and they had a you know a bad reaction
in their arm and so I began to diffuse
that right there early on not waiting 10
minutes or 11 minutes there or you know
they got the flu shot they got a cold I
had to just work on the fact that the
flu shot wasn't a cold or you know they
heard that the neighbor up in nineteen J
got the flu shot her liver blew up you
know but somehow came back together
and but I'm not on my liver blocks on
that so you know say the liver doesn't
really blow up kind of go through that
but but that was the difference it
wasn't that they were any difference if
they here to their belief they weren't
on the web they were listening to the
neighbor of 19 J they were listening to
their BMO they were listening to
somebody else in the family but that's
what's there does that make sense the
closest you know I think what this does
is this changes a conversation from one
where people say you know are you saying
I'm racist to say let's think about how
we could all be meeting decisions that
might be different we are not above
certain and that's not started it
doesn't affect this review means in the
course of effects and so that would
start tipping Robert Phillips talk about
that and then finally it's the issue of
mistrust he talks about the Tuskegee
syphilis study he says this issue missed
this you know the tainted a whole
populations perspective on health and
health care right and it's not just a
scheme he talks about it it's medical
experimentation that segregation it's
racism is discrimination vestiges that
we still see today in the way our health
care system is organized and he talks
about this and this has played out a
large serving by the cosmic Family
Foundation where they ask several
thousand patients in the past have you
been ever treated unfairly in the health
care system based on your race ethnicity
thirty five percent of blacks 36 plus or
Latinos say they've been treated unfair
the health care system based on their
race to the sea but here's the kicker in
the future are you concerned about being
treated unfairly the health care system
based on your race ethnicity 65 percent
of blacks are a 58% is concern about
being treated unfairly a health care
system based on the residency
these are people who we may have never
seen why did it seem for the first time
is my patient but the white coat I wear
the hospital I sit in our nation's
history the city's history is all
sitting in that room with me
and if I don't acknowledge it the
therapeutic relationship is a
if I don't begin to just acknowledge and
mistrust might exist in that
relationship and I think why would
Phillips give that voice
so to summarize the eye alignment to
just end with what we can do the ILM
talks without increasing awareness
having discussions like this moving it
from this act into space to say we have
evidence it shows us is real let's get
past that let's figure out what we can
all do
making our systems more supportive
supporting the therapeutic relationship
collecting race ethnicity data because
we can monitor for disparagement less we
collect that data and that's a hard pill
to swallow for a lot of nations in the
communities in our communities who say
well why do you want to know my race you
know I'm concerned about me do you want
to know because you're going to treat me
differently we have to change that
message to say we need to make sure
you're between you're being treated the
right way by collecting your race doing
work in quality improvement using
evidence-based guidelines not just about
doctors for multi disciplinary teams and
thinking about all the people who are
involved in the health care team and
community outreach is really a central
part of this work workforce diversity
very quickly mine orange 30% of
population about six percent of
physicians ok only four percent of
faculty u.s. medical schools are for
underrepresented minorities and now that
four percent twenty percent
teach the foreign story black medical
schools in the three u.s. accredited
medical schools on Miami Puerto Rico
just to give you a sense of lack of role
modeling mentoring you know diversities
is not there meet Iverson for a lot of
differences it's not just about training
Latino doctors or black doctors to go
care for their own and go work in these
teams we need to leadership and
diversity and leadership as well and
that was one of our messages we talked
about the importance of interpreter
services oceany can't get a good history
in the presence of a language barrier we
talked about
provider education around health
disparities around this field of
cultural competence and clinical
decision making how a race ethnicity
culture class all effective way to make
clinical decisions how do we help
patients be responsible in this year
responsibility too but we have to help
them more effectively navigate the
system help a person like my widow who
the doctor can say the sky is falling
and she'd say see they'll go
right yes doctor yes talk to us doctor
because she didn't feel comfortable she
didn't know that it was her right to ask
the question or to acknowledge when it
wasn't when she didn't understand or she
didn't agree and so we need to empower
our patients in that way and give them
permission what the know that we need
you as a partner and we need to do more
research research is essential to figure
out what works what we need to do and
how we can do it better now to end what
can we do what can we do in our
day-to-day work I'm not focused
particularly on a clinical scenario but
and cultural competence clinically but I
think it's all these things that I
mentioned and no matter what area of the
topics I have found so far that you can
touch on you should be thinking about
whether it be policy whether it be
system design whether it be research
whether it be education we all stand to
play a role in this on the clinical side
but I do believe that when we're caring
for patients and there are a different
culture their culture that we have any
background or we don't have a lot of
experiences we need to have a framework
that we can apply to that patient a set
of concepts a set of ideas that we can
help that individual patient be our
teacher that we can use to learn what
social and cultural factors matter to
that patient because unfortunately what
we see all too often in the area of
cultural Commons is what I call the
manual the menu based approach the
museum based approach with cultural
competence which you know takes the
Latino patient and puts them behind a
glass case that says there is the Latino
patient and then I think oh patient is
fatalistic they like it what you can
call them Senor Senor and they like it
when you pop it on the back and that's
the way you have to manage though in the
patient I mean all of you know
understand there's incredible diversity
everybody likes them you're nice to them
you know everybody likes when you're
popular that there's there's no three
unifying characteristics to know that
are going to guide you caring for
populations clearly there are things we
can and should learn about our
communities without a doubt and so I'm a
classy not
it absolutely does but where it becomes
problematic is where you begin to see a
patient and you say I learned that all
lives are mistrustful so you know I'm
going to assume that this person's in
this Trussell that's not what Robin
quills is talking about Robin Phillips
is saying understand it might be there
and just acknowledge it
and maybe ask a question to see if it's
an issue to that patient that patient
may say you know for me I'm empowered
I'm cool you know I'm able to fight
myself I'm not mistrustful but at least
the fact that you've asked a question
like a question I asked of all my
patients have you ever had a bad
healthcare transaction no matter what
did you not like or like about your last
doctor and very quickly you will see
that they may say oh you know that
doctor never never once sent me letters
with my lab results and I know I'm
wondering why was that and then you're
gonna say you know what
here's you're only gonna make sure you
get a letter every time if you have a
question you just call me and something
very simply I could do so much to build
trust and so what we're talking about
here's what we call a patient based
approach to crosswalk repair which is
understanding what key social and
cultural factors matter for that patient
not in a two-hour anthropologic
interview because we don't have that
luxury but using it in a targeted
fashion like a review system certain key
questions that you could ask that you
could get up because many times you will
be caring for people when you have no
clue about their background then what do
you do you have to be won't be aware of
these key issues and you need to assess
that we call our core cross-cultural
issues spouses communication how people
communicate
understanding somebody's saying yes dr.
Steele if I see them to remain anonymous
and they're all what you're saying you
need to shift gears and change your
style of communications than that have
that patient or the strong patient who's
going to be like you know an incredible
pain is not going to say a thing you
need to be able to pick that up and so
you have a radar screen for styles of
communication for mistrust for how
people make decisions in the Western
medical model the individual patient is
a decision maker but in fact what we see
is that in many cultures you know
involving a spiritual leader family now
there's this really an essential way of
the city's always decisions are being
made so that's what we call a key core
across the solution you need to assess
it for each patient the role of the
physician you know we think well you
know everybody needs health care
absolutely but some people may go to
five places before they come see a
healthcare provider they may use three
home remedies we need to balance it out
that notes will pay for them to tell us
because it's safer if they tell us and
you to work with them and say you know
if you want to have garlic for your
lover sure that's fine please also if
you take this medication it will help
you with your high blood pressure
you know let's find a midway point when
we negotiate the fishes well we
acknowledge their values and beliefs and
anything work with that traditions
customs spirituality really
understanding that understanding that if
you have a diabetic who's Muslim is
going to be fasting for Ramadan for a
month and they're on insulin from sunup
to sundown they're not anything you need
to be able assess best you can manage
there and have a good conversation about
their or their job as witness and they
don't accept blood products and they
need surgery I mean the examples are
limitless and more than I can discuss
now but understanding traditions customs
spirituality taking that into account I
think it's very very important and
sexual and gender issues this is your
non sexual orientation and gender is all
very very important those are what we
call it to the court across colleges
this is a lecture in and of itself
getting on the meaning of the illness
how do you understand the flu shots are
gonna not I'm not gonna give you a
lecture about the pros and cons let me
begin with how you understand it and go
from there let's dance together not when
you do my dance here in your desk over
there and I smoke a little bit of time I
have and then we're not communicating
not stating that the patient's
understanding of their condition
determining the social context it's a
lot more than just asking a patient
whether they drink whether they use
substances what type of work they do and
whether they're married those are
important questions but we need to get
at their balance between their social
supports and social stresses right now
we're at time this great social stresses
that's going to impact patients ability
to manage their condition it's going to
increase the depression we need to
understand it right now under the world
of living and so getting at that social
context is important environment change
language and literacy blanket controls
are all key things that we need to
assess in social context and finally
negotiation again meeting people halfway
now on the story conference environment
change is critically important you know
we need to understand what people's
previous health care experience was like
and I want to just tell a quick story
when I was in practicing here so many
years back I had a good get ready to see
a patient for the first time and I walk
into my office and the clerk you know he
has me this
and has a big scarlet letter all right
difficult patient and you know what that
means you get something like that you're
like man I got a bad start today fast so
he got said what smile she always likes
to be seen early my mom's come like six
hours early for appointments you know
that's what she does she all right okay
go in and I have a bunch of patients I'm
saying but you know her appointments at
two o'clock in something nine o'clock in
the morning and I'm going back and forth
I'm hiding my charges a Mexican American
once by 81 years old and finally I get
her in about noon I get her into my
office I see her you know gonna be
squared away and I leave and I go to the
clerk I see you guys legal impatience
difficult patient you know just just I
got you know just give her a 10 o'clock
appointment because you're always
probably give her afternoon plus your
telephone
okay Michelle laughs it's okay it's fine
you ever talk about appointment you know
and three months later I come in it's
nine o'clock yes it's a hot one when
she's sitting in it I'm like perfect you
know we close the gap you it's great and
I go to the clerk did you see these
biblical patients you guys yeah why
don't you ask the guy who opened the
building what time she came to and I
said what do you mean well yeah she was
outside at 4:30 in the morning on that
you know I said Wow
but I have soft right and I moved to
visit back and I bring her in I said you
know I can't give you an early
appointment so I'm a freaking pinch of
town outside of practice you know I
can't have me do that you know what and
I got this great cross-cultural question
asker why do you come in surah great
right brilliant and she looks at me and
she explains it to me in the next week
she comes in when I see her next and she
brings me a picture this is her previous
healthcare experience community health
center and by California seven o'clock
in the morning one doctor one there's
400 people pshh people with their you
know kids lunch that was the priest on
Thursday she wasn't trying difficult it
was her experience that comes to doubt
the smile and know that she
she didn't want to see and so we labeled
her difficult patient when all it was
was just kind of working within her
context understandable and when I left
New York she'll only come two hours
early so we were getting away but the
point is you know it's so easy to not
take that next step just ask that next
basic question that will help us expose
a patient's perspective so I think
that's a critical part and I think we
need to also the two other points on
make as I close we need to be whereas
third time you just understand how it
happens beware if understand its
mechanism understand what we're being
commissioning and really check ourselves
when we say these patients for any
reason whatsoever
and double-check our clinical decision
and finally as it relates to trust being
aware of mistrust technology's potential
and providing focus reassurance and
negotiating with patients negotiating
with patients I think is the most
essential piece of this so let me just
end by hopefully sharing with you and I
think it's nothing to disparities in
health and health care exists social
cultural factors impact what we all
communicate not just with patients but
with each other and it has an impact on
everything we do every day and I do
believe that we have responsibility we
have a capacity every day to engage in
activities that can help us identify and
address racial and ethnic disparities in
healthcare and so hopefully we feel
empowered by this conference by the work
being done here to make a difference
every day and I'll say I feel incredibly
hopeful I've been at this for about 10
years now and not only do I feel hopeful
in that this issue is becoming more
mainstream that there are more
conferences like this that I get more
emails from students every day that are
saying can you know Kent I want to do
work on disparities and I see this here
but I think I feel very hopeful because
as we look at our new generation of
Americans I see such an energy around
equity around equality that's been
unparalleled and unprecedented and I
think we need to harness that in a very
new power
direction so with that thank you all so
much and how to take a few questions
okay we we have time for one question
yes okay okay I'm surprised to be honest
with you I think it's it's a it's a
greatness justice in many ways and I
think what it is is somebody trying to
do something that kind of makes sense
but for doing the very perverse way you
know I think you want to it be nice to
figure out an objective way I think what
the trend is a scarce resource is trying
to figure out you know how to get the
scarce resource into the into the body
of somebody who's not going to waste it
I don't mean that negative way but who's
gonna take care of it but that's a hard
thing you know people make life changes
on a dime when difficult things happen
to them it's a very difficult thing to
assess and particularly that will
discuss abusers demeaning a patient you
know for comments put they're doing more
objective way there really should be in
your understand correct on what the
evidence says about our ability to to
identify other patients going to be
compliant it says so much about letting
some of the shortcomings of our system
and I think it puts many people like
Robert Phillips had a significant just
the story ended up quite well a very
kind of twisted way but if you got a
transplant but not right but not the
wait what's that a good story to end on
a positive note
he very easy policy analyst you know in
San Francisco you can see I think the
power of his stories does he break
stereotypes she's not somebody who's not
in the know he looks like a person who
can navigates talk about the literature
everything right this video was
developed several years you know
probably going back seven eighty years
now and there was a woman named of
Vanessa Grubbs who was a internist who
was using this video for teaching had a
chance to meet him at a conference and
once you know what these up a
romance right and so they began seeing
each other and and you know he ended up
shortly after he started seeing her
finding out that he was on the wrong
list and so he was online this is a
person you can see Roberts a smart guy
but he was on some list that that he was
gonna get on a new list and he dropped
back up in other year you know real
nightmare and so I'm the nose to him she
went and got herself tested and it ended
up she was a match man
she subsequently gave Robert one of her
kidneys but I just want to end on that
very positive note and he's doing great
and I think he's become a champion and
tonight I honor him and discourage for
putting a story out that I hope it meant
something to you like it means to me
he's a good friend
so thank you also underscore that this
is our fourth year and from my
perspective
but I think you know I am full of this
this this product and so I just have to
ask his mother the sand so you give her
standing ovation Oh towards that you
might have Martha when I was gonna come
okay well they have to stand up on
behalf of my mom is ready we are
presenting you in our first year we
honor dr. Muriel Muriel Etzioni who had
a wonderful career has continued to
mentor so we established an award in her
honor and it's called the dr. Muriel
petty Emmy Award for outstanding service
and mentoring to eliminating health
disparities honoring Joseph's Betancourt
and D F th director disparity solution
center senior scientist Mass General
Hospital Institute for Health Policy
director multicore indication national
hospital and faculty Department of
Medicine Harvard Medical School for your
leadership an increasing minority that
could been into the Health Professions
and your pioneering work to eliminate
racial ethnic disparities and improve
cross-cultural medical care are 6 mm I
and our conference
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu